we heard Eric Andre really really butth
hurt about the show Prank panel yeah
yeah he quit the show three times in the
first seven days it was very traumatic
for him starting out I think it came
down to he's used to being the hammer
and not the nail you understand what I'm
saying yes I love you okay I love you I
really do please help me out here please
all right Kimble's having to call me and
I call he's like quit I'm like what cuz
he had pranked me that Friday what does
that look like when he pranks you it
didn't go so good he brought out a stun
wand and hit me with it okay see I think
you guys were kind of maybe Loosely
interchanging the idea of prank with
assault I don't think yeah I don't know
is it assault when I go after you guys
on jackass I mean certainly not on
jackass but I think that Eric Andre it's
a prank yeah it's